everybody welcome back to park attacks
now I'm still a little bit sick and I
was on a crazy capsaicin high edges a
super spicy curry in any case that's why
my voice is still not sounding the best
but let's just get into archipelago
adventures and see what we can make out
of the park now the goal I see is pretty
high again there are some optional goals
that I'm probably not going to reach
ever but this scenario is definitely a
bit more strict than everything so far
we need to get a certain operating
profit instead of a certain amount of
guests we need to have no loan nets and
we need to get an experience rating of
at least 70% now the experience rating I
think that'll be fine
we had a similar thing on Nova Labs but
the rest of the goals are gonna be a
little bit tough at least tougher than
what we've seen so far so I think it was
a good idea to do an overlap first now
this is a really interesting scenario
it's got a bit of an unusual map at
least not something that we've seen so
far so this is a actually park attacked
in-game terrain generation there's not
really been tempered with it much I
believe so it generates all of these
different little islands okay now I can
definitely tell that there's larger
islands right here in the map and then
the surrounding islands are just much
more sporadic but yeah we just get these
different islands with some water in
between it and a pretty small map
actually let me just check real quick if
we have any other oh god I always forget
where to check this stuff there we go
yeah we don't get any other land so
that's gonna be a bit of a challenge and
then as for the rides oh we don't get a
lot actually we do get some good
coasters so that's gonna make things a
little bit more easy and some pretty
good stalls I suppose all right so I've
got a pretty good idea of what I want to
do with this scenario I just want to
stick to the style that the scenario
already gives me go for a sort of
tropical colorful kind of vibe and see
how that works out and yeah that's about
it
let's get started alright so first off
I'm actually going to remove this island
in the middle of the scenario which
gives me a little bit less space to work
with so from a gameplay perspective it's
a pretty dumb decision
quite honest but I think it just looks a
little bit better with that Island out
of the way we have this small little
lake this this more waterfront ish area
in the middle of the park now and I
always like to have something like that
to build the scenery around and make
some vistas so my idea originally was to
put a rollercoaster on that little
island on the other side of the lake
so that when you get into the park you
have this kind of Main Street area that
opens up to this little waterside
Bulevar where on the other side of the
water you have this this coaster kind of
like well there's there's a lot of cases
like this in real life it was sort of
inspired by Hyde Park in Germany at this
point but it also looks pretty similar
to let's say for instance the picture
here area in this Neyland California
Adventure yeah that's the name of the
park so that always works quite nicely
and then I also decided to put some flat
rights on this side of the water flat
rides are always my sort of ride of
choice at the start of a scenario not
just because they're really easy and
simple to place it doesn't take much
time and money but they're also just
really good fillers for a park I don't
want to you know lose all of my money to
one roller coaster and then have nothing
else for the guests to spend their time
on I'm still not too knowledgeable about
the guests behavior in this game to be
honest but I do have a pretty good
suspicion that they'll probably leave
the park if they've got nothing more to
do and the more rights you have no the
more time they'll be able to sink into
rides either at the end of the day or
between riding coasters and the more
money you can suck out of them so I
think flat rides are pretty important to
get as a foundation which is why I like
to build these things first before I
move into any rollercoasters I guess
from a realistic perspective it also
makes some sense think you always want
to try to have more flat rights than
roller coasters and definitely want to
try as a real theme park to also have a
lot of flat rides around which are
pretty inexpensive compared to roller
coasters but do make it seem like
there's a lot to do in the theme park
so we've got to medium thrill rides I
suppose with the Riptide and the twister
actually quite like the roof on the
twister this time it's a bit of a new
design but even though it's really
simple it's just a simple pointy glass
roof I quite like the diagonal cornices
on it so I might try that again a few
times especially in the reflection of
the Sun it works out a little bit better
than I expected
so we've got that and then a ferris
wheel ferris wheels next to water is
always the best combination I think or
maybe on a hill is also pretty cool but
Ferris wheels are Ferris yeah first
wheel are always like the go-to ride I
think if you've got like a waterfront
Boulevard or something like that anyway
it's it's time to move on to the scenery
I wanted to build a small Main Street as
you get into the park and for a while I
was wondering what I wanted to do in
terms of what kind of style of
architecture I wanted to follow in this
park given that this is the second
tropical ish scenario that I'm trying to
tackle you know I've tried to work on
called caldera before but I wanted to go
for a different style this time around
and looking at the entrance and the
depot building there isn't too much to
build your style on there it's just a
very simple tropical building so I
wanted to lift some of the colours from
that but I also wanted to you know make
this more than just a simple nondescript
overall tropical the themed Park so
eventually I figured I might as well try
and turn this into a Dutch Caribbean
colonial architecture park so I'm gonna
stray away from politics here I just
like these buildings on their own what
they look like I think is quite cool
they look quite tropical and festive
with very colorful colour schemes and
just a great mix of different materials
so they're they're really fitting the
tropical environment I think but at the
same time they've got a slight Dutch
touch to them I suppose a lot of these
buildings have Dutch Gables and Dutch
details so even if the myth the use of
materials is very
and they're very colorful which makes
them undeniably Caribbean at the same
time they have that Dutch colonial
architecture to them so yeah I think
that's a nice and easy way to give this
park a unique tropical theme that's
still a specific theme rather than just
an overall broad tropical idea of a
theme and here also I did mess up a
little bit because this whole ending
looks good in my head with the main
street on this side of the path and the
flat rides next to the depot but then I
realized that I didn't actually have any
good way to supply these stores so
here's just a quick little depot
building I also forgot to put some trash
thing next to this but I don't think
it's too much of an issue because the
actual park border is very close by here
but if I build another food courts or
something like that I'm definitely gonna
have to not forget to put its rationing
there it also took quite a bit of effort
to hide this whole back street area from
the the queue line of the carousel but
in the end I think the queue line of the
carousel has a positive scenery rating
so yeah just putting lots of trees and
fences in the way usually works to keep
your scenery rating positive even if
there's some backstage things really
close by I do like how that sort of
becomes a thing to always think about
especially given that you're judged on
experience rating in this Park which I'm
not sure how much that is affected by
scenery but apparently scenery does play
a role so experiences will be lower if
you don't really hide your backstage
areas well enough now onto the the
coaster the long-awaited
actual you know stuff flagship
attraction of the park I suppose I
wanted to build a looping coaster here
just because that's the only pretty
thrilling ride that we have so far and I
didn't want to make the mistake of
Victoria Lake again when there's not a
super thrilling ride in the park and all
the people that the mounts thrill rides
are gonna destroy everything so this is
just about
I had to work with and I think in the
end it works all right it's just a
simple swatch cough looping coaster with
a loop and then some a little bit of
meandering layouts with some curves and
Hills and back into the station I
suppose that this would probably be more
of a latest generation swatch cough
coaster like jet line or liseberg Bonham
I actually don't know how old jet line
is but in any case it's not like one of
the first ones this one is definitely
looking a little bit more adventurous
but I still think it would be believable
as a swatch cough coaster now aside from
building able to bring its money much
active here will also make something
that would work quite well as a skyline
since this is the general sort of
entrance area and you get to see this
coaster across the water the entrance
area so I wanted to have something with
a loop just over the water to have that
cool skyline to look at and then the
hill over the the pathways there I think
works out pretty well as well and
overall it should be the thing you know
if we were just demanding never in the
universe here and where it's walking
into the park from the Main Street this
should look pretty neat and that's also
where my inspiration from Hyde Park came
in even I know it sounds like a stretch
Hyde Park has this coaster called big
loop which is a bakoma double loop
double corks which even though it's an
absolute torture machine it looks really
cool across the water if you if you're
in the end I think in general Hyde Park
is a really good idea of how to make you
know coasters or show with them on show
you're on when you're on a path and how
to make these brilliant looking skylines
using coasters they're not only my
favorite kosis the rabbit they
definitely look pretty good from an
override perspective so honestly I think
there's there's something something as
well now the rest of this I am keeping
principle station building was inspired
actually by the station building for the
Python in efteling which is another bit
of a stretch I guess it's also another
vakama double loop double corkscrew
coaster the first one actually and
world but it's just a slightly different
style this time even though the station
has a sort of similar shape this one is
using more wooden elements painted
wooden elements and more of a tropical
vibe and here I'm also trying to bring
back the colors of the entrance building
and the deeper building that we get from
the start of the scenario to still make
it fit into the overall look of the
scenario well and what the intention of
the scenario was in terms of scenery
I've seen if people also take scenario
and build all of the buildings in this
kind of style but while I think that
looks amazing and some of the people
have done for this scenario look great
I just want to you know experiment a
little bit more with some of the things
that I build and even though it might
work out all the time
things like building some Dutch colonial
architecture I think it works quite
nicely and it's just fun to experiment
with different building styles as well
so yeah actually I changed the colour
scheme of the coaster here for a bit I
cut this out of the video but I spent an
insane amount of time trying to figure
out a good colour scheme for this
coaster whenever I tried different like
very tropical bright color schemes it
just didn't really feel right and I
ended up setting with the simple white
supports and orange track that I started
out with only thing that I made
different is that I made the orange of
the track a little bit darker or
saturated to I don't know feel a bit
different from the standard orange trick
that you get from this coaster because
if you just build it without changing
the color scheme you get a very similar
colors came to this and I didn't want to
make it look as though I didn't change
any of the colors I think this bright
orange also works quite well as a
tropical looking color well at the same
time being quite believable as a swatch
cough looping coaster because I think my
biggest problem with all of the bright
colour schemes that I tried is that they
just don't feel rights for this coaster
type because most of the ones in real
life they're quite old and the time
creams of coasters weren't as bright and
as a venture and as adventurous as they
are nowadays so
a lot of these coasters in real life
just have very simple color schemes so I
do want to you know make it fit with
that as well and this small building
over here isn't actually a restaurant it
could be it actually kind of looks like
one and it looks like there's some kind
of stalls inside but really all that
same sex machine because you know I want
my guests to get more cash and spend
more money on my theme park but I guess
it sort of looks like a restaurant which
I think works quite well with this whole
sort of central Little Lake area so yeah
just like the position of a building
there and I couldn't figure out how to
make it an agressor on the cash machine
it is and finally for this part of the
time-lapse I'm building I'm building
this drop tower over here which is the
same one that I built in the last
episode just because it's one of the few
thrill rides that I have currently at my
disposal actually and I just want to
prevent people from not having thrilling
enough rides and break everything in the
park so this thing even though is that a
little bit a little bit there just to
make sure it had slightly higher stats
this thing should have goo stats for
Super Bowl seekers I'd like to also
somewhere instead of breaking all of
inches so I pray that this is gonna s
time I was you know is still not sure if
the park would run a really good profits
but so far it's doing pretty well and
I'm careful with taking loans as well
because not only do I need to finish the
park without loans I also need to get
her in profit every month and when you
have a loan you need to pay rent on that
and yeah that's gonna make reaching the
goal of this park a little bit more
difficult that said we do get money for
reaching certain guests ago so I think
I'm gonna be using mostly that money to
dance this park in any case let's take a
look at how it's doing all right here we
are and if you're wondering how I got so
rich so quickly well that's a secret
that the the rich people wouldn't want
you to know now actually I just reached
the goal of 250 people in the park so
that means that I got eight thousand
dollars which is quite a bit actually I
didn't expect to get that much money but
it's a pretty decent amount and I don't
think it's gonna be able
to finance the next big roller coaster
especially since I've been eyeing this
winged coaster over here and I kind of
feel like that would be a really cool
addition to the park but god these
things are really expensive so we'll see
what happens with that but uh yeah the
park is doing quite alright I think I'm
just about a third of the way there
given that I'm earning $500 a month at
the moment and there's not too much else
to raise the price on I've raced the
price on the food and drinks quite a bit
even though I can probably still that do
that a little bit more I'm not quite
sure really where the margin is on that
but I'm asking about $15 for the coaster
which is absolutely ridiculous
never do this in real life this is a
very unethical but here I think it's
alright actually maybe maybe the only
coaster that's ever been that expensive
to ride is Olympia looping and London
and Hyde Park I heard that was upwards
of 12 pounds so a very similar amount
but in any case yeah crazy expensive but
earning some pretty good money here so
yeah I think it's it's a good time to
keep going the way I have been going
that said maybe I have been lacking in
the staff Department only three janitors
might not be quite enough especially if
that okay no he's actually gonna go
there I think he's gonna clean it is oh
no he's still he's bringing trash
somewhere okay so we definitely need
another janitor aside from that though
pretty good amount of stuff I think
experiences aren't quite that great yet
but I think this will get better as I
open more rides at least so far that's
been happening and aside from that it
doesn't look like there's any vandalism
issues or anything like that just a bit
of a very small tip I tend to use the
decoration thing of you I suppose to
check for vandalism because the
vandalism one it highlights the separate
objects and makes them red if they are
vandalized which helps but a vandalized
object will also make that square read
so as long as everything is green it
should be easier to look for vandalized
objects by looking in decoration because
then there will be one red square in the
middle of all of that green and
pretty much tells you that there's
something vandalized in there but yeah
it looks like we're doing pretty good
I'll get to the POVs and stuff like that
at the end of the scenario so I think
it's time to start building some stuff
and see if I can actually fit a winged
rider somewhere let's go all right now
space is pretty limited here so this
isn't going to be a very large wing
rider but I am able to buy some new land
on this island over here which is gonna
help out a lot so that is basically
where most of the layout is going to be
and the layout itself was most of all
inspired by Phoenix interpolant that
wasn't really what I intended to do but
it just works out the best with the
limited space here mostly because until
Phoenix was built all of the wing riders
usually had a dive drop which meant that
they just those straight down off to the
lift Hill straight into a barrel roll
and half a loop either that or they had
just a straight drop at the beginning of
the layout or some kind of launch in the
case of whatever the name of that
coaster in holiday world is but Phoenix
is a bit of an exception here it
actually features a small curve to the
right before the drop and that works out
really well on this coaster as well to
make it go to the direction of that
little island there so that's what I
decided to end up with and then the rest
of the way how it is surprisingly
similar as well I really didn't intend
the layout to be this similar or at
least the first part of it but this is
just what fits the best I wanted to try
and put some zero-g rolls or something
like that in there
but really I only have space for a quick
airtime Hill into that a moment
inversion and a quick helix which is
almost exactly what Phoenix in turbulent
looks like in fact I think Phoenix would
be a coaster that you can very easily
recreate in Park attacks and I remember
the first time I saw it or I saw some
renders of it before it was built it
just reminded me of rollercoaster tycoon
3 wing riders because it's a very simple
layout in a general L shape
it mostly just has 90 degree curves so
there's nothing you could you know
there's no very difficult parts of it to
recreate it's a very simple and easy
layout but at the same time I also think
it's an amazing coaster I really like it
it's one of my favourite coasters in the
Netherlands and it's just an amazing
addition to the pike of toverland in any
case the second parts of the layout is a
bit different we've got a corkscrew over
there which is just about the best way
that I could figure out how to get to
the other side of the station into
another airtime Hill and finally ending
up with a helix back into the station so
it's definitely quite similar to Phoenix
maybe a tiny bit longer but still a
pretty short ride but then again it also
loses most of its speed by the end of it
I don't think there's much potential
wasted there so I think it's pretty fine
also yeah I have noticed that I say in
any case way too often I don't know for
how long that's been something that I
repeat a lot in my videos but I think
it's been going on for quite a while I'm
sort of aware of it I just can't stop
doing it if it's really annoying I can
try to do something about it but so far
yeah I'll drop it a few times per
episode and try to leave it at that so
the station is pretty simple just
decided to build some wooden framework
and put a roof over it I was considering
for a while to also turn this into a
bunch of Dutch colonial Caribbean houses
but that doesn't really work out very
well with the wing Rider cars this is
always a difficult right to build a
station for because the hitbox of the
coaster is very large it's super wide so
you always need an open space of at
least the three tiles so that the
coaster doesn't Ram its way through
anything so this is just about the best
shape for that I also decided to build
some catwalks on the side that I had to
get pretty creative with doing the
fences on the side of that as well
because fences in the game they always
sent up to a full grid space and
the the width of the cars is really too
great spaces so it's sticking out half a
grid space on either side of the track
so I was only able to build some sort of
makeshift catwalks
with these diagonal roof cornice pieces
so it's not the best solution but I
think it does a decent job at looking
like a catwalk and I just wanted to have
that as well for I don't know I guess
the suspense of disbelief that this
would be a real ride
I've decided long ago to give up on
making any trend for tracks or putting
storage sheds everywhere because that's
maybe a bit of a stretch for a scenario
play but I did want to add catwalks
wherever I can really especially if it
helps to fit the coaster into the theme
a little bit better what's also
interesting actually is that this is one
of the only if not the only coasters in
the game that has its own catwalks so
you could see that it has some for the
little so you don't have to build any of
that but most of the other coasters
don't really have any catwalks at all
it's cool that they added the catwalks
that lift Hill they're here though
because I think it's a very typical
thing for winged riders it's what it
gives them their signature look so it's
nice to have it here and the rest of the
ride I just decided to spruce up with
some foliage some shrubbery and some
rock work and that is pretty much it now
I wanted to finish the rest of the park
as well just by adding some flat rides
here and there and adding some more
scenery what's also interesting and I
don't know yeah you've already been able
to see it you've been able to see the
green box at the top of the screen pop
up already which is basically the
countdown for reaching the objectives of
the scenario and when it first popped up
I was just kind of like well [ __ ] I
didn't expect to reach the goal of this
quickly but it turned out to be a little
bit harder than that so basically you
need to get to $1,500 profit a month but
you also need to get a minimum of 70% in
the experience rating I need to hold
both of these calls for two
consecutive months and it's the last
part that actually makes this really
difficult because usually what happened
here is that I was making a good amount
of profits but at some point a
thunderstorm came by and the Wrights had
to close and people didn't want to write
their rides anymore in the rain so every
time that happened the profit dipped
below a thousand five hundred and also
any time that your experience rating
dips below seventy percent even if it's
just down to 69 percent you lose the
whole progress that you had for the two
months so you could see that bar in the
little pop up on top of the screen
slowly crawl toward reaching the
objectives many times but it never
actually happens and yeah it's still
gonna be a bit of a challenge to try and
figure out how to actually reach the
goals of the scenario for two months in
a row in any case I dare I win again but
yeah I decided to finish this part of
the scenario just to fill everything up
there was just some empty spots in the
park and I figured that wouldn't be it
wouldn't be nice to leave that behind
so I decided to put some more buildings
in here and also to make the experience
rating a little bit better make sure to
put some drinks and food stuffs in here
so that people don't get thirsty because
one of the ways apparently in which the
experience rating goes down is if you
don't have enough food or drinks or
similar services for guests think
toilets play quite a role in this as
well but in any case in those in those
cases you'll get a lower experience
rating it's pretty difficult also to get
to that point because experience is
rated at the end of a guests visit so
it's like an exit poll apparently so
even if you improve the park quite a bit
you're only going to see that experience
rating go up later as people enter the
park and have a good experience and
finally leave the park and only on their
exit poll let you know that the park was
awesome so it's there's quite a lot of
factors in that actually and it's quite
hard to prepare for it I'm just trying
my best to make sure that there's enough
services everywhere
and that there's not much vandalism or
anything like that and that there's a
good set of rights as well as that
there's a lot of scenery and that the
park is very immersive I'm definitely
gonna have to get better throughout the
playthrough of the scenarios though
because so far I've never really gotten
a super good experience rating yet and
I've heard that for some of the later
scenarios you need to get a rating of
80% which is gonna be pretty difficult
so far my my rating here has been
dipping below 70% every now and then and
that's I think the biggest reason why I
haven't reached the goals yet so
definitely it's definitely gonna be a
bit of a challenge to get above that in
some of the later scenarios but that's
nothing to worry about so far so to get
back to the scenery things of the whole
story I decided to build a few more of
these Dutch colonial buildings here just
to fit with the style and the rest of
the park it's actually super similar to
the Main Street and this is something
and I figured later there's not a lot to
choose from in real life I would like to
mess with different styles of Dutch
Gables but there's not really too much
to do with that here so really the only
variation here is mostly just the colors
and the specific scenery items that I'm
using everywhere but these buildings are
structurally basically the same as the
buildings on the Main Street and the
little restaurant or really the cash
building on the side of the water there
so I'm also kind of glad that the
scenario is over now because as much as
I like the theme I don't think I would
have been able to explore too many
different kinds of buildings with it now
the final right here is just an
observation tower and I think that
rounds up the rides in the park pretty
well so yeah let's get back into a real
time section and see if we can finally
reach the objective so I've been able to
hold the goals for quite a while and
apparently I just reached the goal of
500 guests in the park I don't actually
know what that gives me I didn't notice
getting anything from it
okay now so it's just an it's just the
challenge goal to get before the end of
June year three so I'm definitely not
making that I think it's a good time to
check this coaster though and by the
looks of it
yeah the experience rating is really
high right now so I don't think I'm
gonna fail for that however I'm only
three hundred dollars above a thousand
five hundred so if it starts raining or
some shenanigans like that right now I'm
probably screwed but yeah we'll see I
can always leave the scenario running
until I finally hit it first three
months in a row so here's the winged
coaster which I also should mention the
color scheme is lifted straight out of
my wild ego from Dollywood just because
it looks really cool so yeah overall
it's a pretty smooth layout I think I
had some troubles trying to make sure to
put all of this scenery around it and
not actually have the cars clip through
it because the hitbox of this thing is a
little bit smaller actually than the
trains as it turns out it's also a
little bit slow in that inversion but I
mean that just gives you extra hang time
and I think that's more of a positive
thing anyway so as you can see it's a
pretty short layout but I do like it
and given the amount of space that we
get here I think it would be hard to do
much more with this coaster really
there's also another interesting section
at the end where there's one track
section that sort of dips down and go
straight again and also on banks
throughout one continuous section so
that's just one of the ways in which I
still think it's it's best to use the
autocomplete feature now I'd also like
to look at the looping coaster so let's
actually see if we get another train
over here so far we're reaching the
goals so that's super good alright let's
get this train over here this thing is
still making more money than the wing
rider actually just because there's more
people riding it I don't know if that's
because it's slightly less intense so
there's more people dare to ride it or
because it's closer to the entrance and
there's just more people around there
but yeah this is the most popular ride
of the park ever since the beginning so
also just a pretty simple layout nice
little airtime Hill over here some over
banked turns
it's not really to over-banked actually
it's a little bit slow here but it's
definitely slightly banked and back into
I think another airtime Hill over here
it yep and there's the helix a pretty
swatch copy feeling layout I think at
least decently believable so yeah that's
for the major coasters in the park no
junior comes through this time because I
didn't really feel like there was enough
space to build something like that
anywhere in the park and I also didn't
want to spend time building another one
of those because I'm probably gonna do
that quite a bit again in the future I
should also say that when you're
starting out a park in Park Tech's I
think it's actually better to start out
with a very intense coaster rather than
a junior coaster because even though the
junior coasters might be cheaper they
really don't earn you as much money and
the coasters the the the more intense
coasters are a good way to make the
thrill-seeking guests happy as well so
what else do we have we've got the
observation tower over here the chair
swing here which i think is also yeah
the singles make some decent money and
some of the other new rides are just
this double ferris wheel over here which
people are mostly ignoring it's pretty
far away and the bumper cars
so yeah altogether I am pretty happy
with the park and how it turned out
actually I managed to complete it pretty
quickly so yeah there we go it's been
one of the shortest scenarios to
complete so far even though it was quite
difficult to reach the goals
actually yeah I quite like the challenge
about that I wanted to just add a bit to
that as well and give a bit of a review
of this scenario almost because this is
one of the snows that I didn't make I
really quite like the different
challenge of not being forced to get a
certain amount of guests in the park but
rather instead having this operating
profit and experience rating especially
for two months in a row so it makes sure
that you can't really choose your way
into it some way like you really have to
maintain this for quite a long time and
without any loans so it's pretty tough
and I had to tinker a lot with the park
a lot more than some of the scenarios so
far I think but at the same time it was
also
the quickest scenarios to complete so
yeah I really like this this was one of
my favorite scenarios so far and I think
I've also read some people reviewing
this thing before we said that it was
one of their favorite scenarios and I
never actually played this before the
the game came out because even though I
had access to these scenarios I didn't
actually play all of them so yeah this
was a really nice surprise I really like
this scenario so just one final look at
the park before we move on I suppose
yeah let's get back into the main menu
and see what we get so I actually have
no idea what other park we're gonna get
I saved just before reaching the
objective so I think that'll be fine all
right so we got that little entrance
building as a trophy as they're called
and we're gonna move over here I suppose
through the cross way see okay so we got
two branching paths again and over here
we have oh yeah I like that one that's
actually really cool so this is batavia
k which is a really nice scenario not
going to spoil too much of that though
because I unlocked Adventure Island
first so I think it'll be good to play
Adventure Island first so next time
we're gonna play through Adventure
Island I hope you guys enjoyed this
episode and I'll see you all next time